hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pop ghosts now I
know it's been a while since the last
time I played this and a lot of you
probably thought that I was just gonna
abandon and not finish it just like I
did with five nights at candy's 3 well
guess what I ain't gonna do that I'm
gonna finish this probably not in this
one episode because it's been a long
time since the last time I played which
means that I've forgotten pretty much
all the mechanics and then I plan to go
back and finish five nights at candy's 3
which I meant to do a long time ago and
then I always get sidetracked but I
wanna be the very best like no one ever
was alright how the I'm gonna die like I
know I'm gonna die like right away so
that's just a given
Oh All Right see ya cuz I scare him away
like that you know ok which I don't
remember which rooms go to which place
so let's just let's just get it over
with
don't do that why what do I just not get
to look over there the relaxing view up
the windows is not gonna happen for me
ok I see how it is Oh they've probably
already moved way out ah I should panic
I know I should I've completely
forgotten how to play I am going to die
oh it's just it's just evident ok Green
got it called it oh boy
I'm dead I'm dot there's that guy with
the thing that I needed him not to take
that's ok I can I can survive a little
bit I guess Rick oh no where are they
where are they oh well that's a sound to
my left well I see ya see ya dude well
I'm surprised I'm not dead he's going to
the art room what are you gonna doing
the art room huh which one's the art
room again dude I can't even remember
shut it down are you gonna do about it
nothing I'm already missing things oh
man why is it game lagging oh it crashed
Oh shitty tits let's try that again
shall we
and this time hopefully not suck nearly
as much as I just did what if I scream
at you huh how do you uh where's the
birth
oh is that the birthday oh oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no how did he miss her ah
I did get them he wants to go to the aah
I shouldn't be afraid I'm not afraid of
you I'm stronger than you are
why am i pointing my finger like this
I've just got my finger out like this
permanently no that's a no now mr.
weasel Wow okay
all right where's he gonna go next I
should check this room huh that's
important Oh No ah
cerulean got it nailed ah oh god I'm
such an idiot I'm gonna put my finger
down you're still there okay see ya Wow
alright seriously dude go away I thought
I could just look at you that's what I
thought I could do just have a nice
relaxing looky-loo oh don't hi how's it
going friend that that's him I saw did I
see him maybe I saw him they're still
there so that's nice now I'm gonna panic
what a lovely view of you what the [ __ ]
was that red fire passion red that was
weird that was weird
all my power almost went out are you
still back there okay you're still you
a sack of [ __ ] don't do that to me uh
you're gonna go in the the side room or
whatever that is I don't even know I
don't remember what the cameras placed I
don't know where remember where anything
is
I don't know what I'm doing I'm at a
complete loss I'm at a standstill
now you still there okay you're still
there they're still there I'm still here
everyone's fine there's really no reason
to panic I don't remember which room was
that it was that one no that was a
balloon Oh
oh god damn it I'm never gonna be able
to get through this I'm barely 1 a.m. in
I forgot that this game also takes a
long-ass time to get through it I got to
get my bearings together and Oh Jeff
have friend how you doing see you have a
good day at school I read you got it
passion fire I give it I feel it
ah they're just going in the vents good
good good good good good good good
ghanoush baba ganoush you stop you look
in the vents not there yet but you're
gonna be there you're about to be there
who hey wait no stop that
you're bad bad squirrels bad where'd you
go oh no invent look vent look Oh heat
ok
now the heat phase has started and I
just need to not let them get heated no
not that this that and that and heat
there no stop looking at me funny I hate
this I hate this
Oh Oh God I wasn't watching then heat
what where who huh what huh oh did I get
it
I don't know if I got it but panicking
did I get it
I think I got it oh [ __ ] the dye the
friggin Heat oh hello pink okay alright
No oh god the heat hey you get another
piece okay
I think he did I think he funcle' he did
oh god damn it
ah heat okay I can't let him go again
I've got three more hours to not let him
go which is perfectly easy then I can
totally do that and I won't fail ho what
happened where you where you okay you're
going on the birthday room I know I know
that's the birthday right okay heat no
cheat sheet birthday room okay ah no and
look here Oh red and bland and look BAM
okay yeah heat delivered No okay I still
got that in my brain I cannot believe I
got that in my brain if I can control it
there then I might still have a chance
oh that must be the last one he needs
because he's gonna keep going there
because all the parts they aren't
randomly screwing him out there they're
very specific to the room that which
they are in so if I'm able to get that
under way then I should be okay right no
I said no to you okay so the Badgers
gonna be the next red ok bonk and you're
fine okay ow d goody shuddhi downy venti
when t he D we D okay so far so goo okay
4:00 a.m. that's good
hey for hims a fun time for me he sorry
I just scream randomly you did it again
goddamn he's very into that one part
he's very very persistent about that one
okay there wasn't anything else that I
needed to worry about right no heat
ready and heat okay so far so goo oh and
red and punk and out and I'm back he
because he's he's probably yeah I called
that one buddy
Downey PD fami okay it's a good rhythm
it's a good rhythm nope oh god he snuck
in there ah it's like every ten seconds
on the dot buck got you right on your
noggin pop goes the weasel whoo that's
why it's called that ha ha ha 5 a.m. we
can do this we can do this shut it down
okay all right easy peasy
GD we do mean it I mean it once you got
it down to like the last piece it's the
puzzle can't be completed if he doesn't
get the last piece oh oh oh god oh god
oh god oh god pink that this shut down
oh no that was too early
oh no oh no did I goof it please tell me
I didn't goof it oh can you get that if
okay I'm good okay oh those trashy wall
oh I don't like it okay do I get a crawl
through the creepy
[Music]
[Applause]
well okay okay so I'm guessing that
custom night probably has some sort of
truth to it that it's talking about let
me check out the extras first characters
okay species least weasel is the least
weasel green pop goes the weasel is a
singer and leader of pop goes pizzeria
band his design is inspired by the least
weasel his hat was purchased from an
auction and originally originally
belonged to freddy fazbear of course it
did
European badger power color yellow Blake
the Badgers the mechanic and help for
hell had a helper of pop goes pizzeria
it's a sign is inspired by the European
badger his palms have magnetic pads that
help them hold weasel we're phones and
do other things very scary
all right species gray squirrel power
color blue Sarah the squirrel is the
bassist of the Pops goes pizzeria band
her designs inspired by the grey
squirrel she isn't directly connected to
weasel wear but will help pop goes out
on tasks he is set ok red squirrel power
color pink saffron the squirrels the
guitarist of the pop goes pizzeria band
her design is inspired by the red
squirrel her programming was forced her
to become an exact copy of her sister
forrester weird carrion crow
oh so friendly ah so family-oriented oh
no kid would have nightmares about that
thing stone the crows a sign older who
stays outside the Bob goes pizzeria his
design is inspired by the carrion crow
stone isn't connected to anything at all
if you see him moving you're
hallucinating okay I see what's going on
here I see what's going on
TD Winkle impossible mode reward okay Oh
black rabbit power color white black
rabbit is a collection of six black
plastic body parts in the style of toy
Bonnie black rabbits parts are untreated
and unpainted causing them to crumble
the powder overnight pop-goes will try
to build black rabbit no matter what
find out why I don't wanna I don't wanna
oh oh gemstone find the truth okay don't
get those nope nope nope not not okay
alright weird no I do not like that hmm
nope don't like looking at that at all
nope don't like that no no no no don't
like that I'm gonna go away from that
okay that was horrifying okay
so that's it for that but as with all
these five nights at Freddy's games
it never ends there so I'm gonna take a
look at custom night oh okay
so I don't think that I'm gonna try to
beat it on impossible mode oh I'm gonna
give it a go
I'll give it a try but uh this isn't
that good good good night good night to
me or it's a good night never ones gonna
get crunk is that kind of good now we're
looking for well the robos which I am I
know I'm a robo that's obvious
okay good good night good night love you
bye or theorem huh yeah that's not the
birthday and this is the birthday room
oh he already got a piece out I don't
know how we got that that's all he's
going into the art room ah oh no oh I oh
I oh I gotta stop come on man give me a
break
it's trying to look out the window stop
that
I didn't even Oh God power power power
oh the green the bunk Oh panic okay I
just need to look man look I gotta look
just let me look at you
you're so pretty anyone ever tell you
that no where are the where are the
squirrels Oh
God didn't they know I'm king of them
how I'm boned Oh
oh I welp there I go oh oh oh are you
the same about me okay so that's
incredibly difficult I'm not gonna do
that so this has been an interesting
experience I really liked it the only
problem is I didn't like it enough to
dive super deep into the lore and this
is probably gonna sound like I'm being
critical about the game but like I said
I like the game the only problem is I
feel like too much was left up to be
discovered in the story because I think
they were trying to emulate the fact
that five nights at freddy's had a lot
of environmental storytelling and that's
great because it did but but the thing
about this game is it drives a lot off
of the five nights at freddy's lore so i
go into it feeling already familiar with
the scenario that i don't notice the
things that are out of place and again i
don't want to be hyper critical about
this i actually enjoyed the game but it
didn't draw me in the same way as like
joy of creation did which took the
characters yes and inspiration from the
main game but it crafted this completely
new narrative in a different way and
also like the gameplay mechanics was
obviously different and and I didn't
feel as scared going into this one I
felt panicked but not scared you know
what I mean like the enemies didn't
exactly draw me in into curiosity of
what they were or who they were or
terrify me in the same way as the
lovable characters in five nights at
Freddy's did or the horrifying
characters enjoy creation now again I
don't want to compare I'm not comparing
things I'm using things as examples to
just make a discussion and I'm probably
comparing it but I don't want to like
compare it unfairly this was a good game
I just didn't feel compelled to finish
it completely but I did finish it
succinctly so the truth is out there if
you want to find it out for yourself I
provide a link to the game in the
description below and thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down the calm
if you want to see more five nights at
Freddy's fan games or stuff like that
where you have a game suggestion of your
own let me know down there in the
comments as well thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]